on May 27th SpaceX and NASA are
scheduled to launch the first orbital
human space flight from US soil since
the space shuttle program ended in 2011
liftoff the final liftoff of Atlantis
shoulders of the Space Shuttle America
will continue the dream and we view it
as an opportunity but also a
responsibility for the American people
for the SpaceX team for all of NASA but
while SpaceX dominates the headlines
small launch startups face an
increasingly tough trajectory operating
along slim margins with small cash flows
and with funds drying up during the
corona virus pandemic many small
launchers could falter
analysts say as many as 90% of the
hundred-plus companies in the industry
are likely to fail if this happens
thousands of jobs could be lost and
plans for new technologies and research
could be delayed to understand how we
got here you have to go back to 2009
when SpaceX's Falcon one took off
becoming the first major private space
company to successfully launch a
commercial satellite into orbit
investors took notice and funneled more
than twenty billion dollars into
hundreds of small space companies over
the next decade during the same period
demand for small satellites grow
companies like oneweb and SpaceX is
StarLink made plans to launch
constellations of thousands of tiny
satellites that would expand global
internet access other small satellites
were developed to collect navigation
data and detect forest fires from space
some could eventually provide advanced
missile defense for the military so we
put some weather satellites up you know
a couple of years ago they provide
weather to New Zealand few minutes later
they provide weather to Australia in you
know UK and then America and every 90
minutes they're going around the planet
providing data that influences tens of
millions of people's everyday lives and
decisions large rocket launchers like
SpaceX's Falcon Heavy weren't designed
for small relatively inexpensive
payloads for years the only option for
small satellites to get into space was
to piggyback on larger payload flights
where they got dropped off enroute in
orbit for many small satellite startups
and programs this isn't ideal they're
reliant on the bigger payloads which
have their own orbit paths and the small
satellite missions have little control
over delays and scheduling for some this
could mean waiting on the shelf for over
a year which costs money if they can't
afford to wait that could mean some
research programs and new technologies
never make it into orbit this is where
small launch vehicles come in companies
like rocket lab and virgin orbit have
developed lighter payload rockets that
can carry small satellites directly into
orbit
small launch vehicle enables customer to
deliver those satellites to exactly
where they want to go and exactly on the
timeframe that they need experts say
these launchers have the potential to
revolutionize the industry
but as the pandemic continues much of
the financing these companies need to
survive is drying up some of this
funding comes from government contracts
in April the Pentagon said there'd be
fewer defense contracts for at least
three months domestically we are seeing
the greatest impacts in the aviation
supply chain shipbuilding and small
space launch other funding comes from
venture capital today the vast majority
of the capital raised by these small
long providers has been from financial
investors with smaller pools of money
coming from grants or early stage
investors and the key challenge for many
of these companies in a very crowded
market is to continue to draw additional
and larger up size rounds of capital in
order to hit their development
milestones this type of funding has all
but stopped and it isn't expected to
flow back into the small launch industry
for at least the next year experts say
there are just too many of these
companies for all of them to succeed in
a tighter market it's so blatantly
obvious that it's unsustainable to have
so many small launch companies for such
a small market that pandemic has really
pushed the dynamos over a bit faster and
how does point in time is yet to occur
many small rocket startups also won't
have access to some of the stimulus
funds most companies with more than 500
employees are ineligible for Small
Business Administration loans during the
pandemic this includes some small space
startups that are funded by larger
venture capital firms some industry
executives and trade groups are asking
for a change of rules saying the lack of
access is hurting business and could
lead to layoffs although many of the
companies in the space industry have a
favorable exposure to government
spending which tends to be pretty secure
it's also true that they're all
dependent on raising new capital and the
inability to capture a PPP loan could be
the difference between life and death
experts say lack of funding could lead
to consolidation of the sector which
could cost jobs delay research and
innovation and favor more robust
established company
SpaceX is expected to continue to
dominate the industry as it increases
its own small satellite rideshare
program and drives down launch prices
meanwhile the smaller players are
expected to suffer there will be a
massive number of failures though
companies that never make it across the
finish line and that simply due to the
fact that there's not sufficient demand
in terms of the number of launches
required there's not sufficient capital
fundis many companies and quite honestly
there's not enough differentiation
between the technology or the cost that
these companies can deliver